you know when barack obama left the
white house to go pick up five guys
we're gonna go get some burgers 41.
that's what makes five guys a treat and
special
john eckford the ceo of five guys europe
five guys has a global cult following
five guys burgers are fries it was
banging covent garden was the very first
five guys outside of the us we knew that
we weren't gonna be advertising we're
entirely relying on someone tasting a
great burger and crying and telling
their neighbors or their friends it has
to be that's [ __ ] fantastic that
covent garden location sold more than
any in the world it did yeah by far i'm
responsible for 225 restaurants now how
do you stop getting a little bit sloppy
and complacent we've actually gotten
better
the key to that is
[Music]
as the ceo of a business that's gone
through such chaos when was your hardest
time
so i had two young children the fact is
that there were moments where they woke
up and needed both their parents and i
wasn't there
you'll hurt the people you care about
in ways that you don't intend
in ways that you don't understand
so without further ado i'm stephen
bartlett and this is the diary of a ceo
i hope nobody's listening but if you are
then please keep this yourself
[Music]
john
i've i've read quite extensively through
your story and um
i guess my first question is when you
when you think back to your pre-twenties
right
what is that what are the most important
things from that era of your life that
shaped your perspective
and approach
to the world and to business
today
wow
well first i grew up in a very
counter-cultural isolationist family
so we didn't we didn't watch tv we
didn't celebrate birthdays or holidays
and
um
i kind of got up at five a.m to practice
violin for an hour
before school
and had music lessons after school every
day
and
so it was very
different
and i think i always i think i grew up
feeling different with this kind of
[Music]
longing to
have a sense of belonging um and that
was always something that
i was looking for in my
professional life i think
as well
i would have been a fourth generation
doctor if i had gone into medicine
and my father
told me that the profession was changing
and it wasn't so much about patients and
um and doctors and kind of the
relationship that can develop in terms
of health and bringing your you know
your health to your doctor and getting
advice and it was changing in america
dramatically and so he he said you know
don't uh don't do that you know i'm not
encouraging you to do medicine so i knew
i had to kind of find a different
role in life
and i read um anne rand in high school
um and not suggesting that uh
that she's gotten everything right but
one one interesting thing that she did
propose was that there's there could be
something noble
in business be you know being a
successful entrepreneur
could be
a noble thing and
my so the the kind of orientation from
my family was
make sure that you do something
important or
in your life and that meant you know
taking care of other people or doing
something that was
had some
greater purpose to it than kind of just
making money
but that seed of a thought that
being in business could actually be
a noble profession and you actually
could do something important to make
people's lives better um and take care
of people in a different way in business
was kind of i think an important penny
to drop for me um when i was when i was
18. um but yeah it was a it was a it was
a definitely a different
upbringing than than most and that that
sense of belonging is something i've
been searching for my whole life
do you think you've been searching for
that sense of belonging more so than the
average person
um
i think so you know i i think if you
have something in abundance you take it
for granted maybe um and it was
something that i definitely didn't have
and and that i um and i very much felt
um you know an outsider looking in um
and i i saw this you know other other
people had community other kids had
community and
and kind of broad-based friendships and
and a sense of really kind of relaxed
belonging and i kind of always had this
kind of
anxious drive that you know looking for
that um
and you know i think business was um
you know certainly lived that out in the
business world um as well
you you
had a um
quite a journey through
banking and being a
being what we'd call like a a regional
councillor and all these things and
eventually you you came back to the uk
kind of where i wanted to to start this
this story off um in 2010 i believe
that's right um your good friend sir
charles dunstan who was the founder of
carphone warehouse um and you went into
business originally and then you went
went on in search of
um
a new business to sort of partner with
him on
and that's kind of where the five guys
stories begins
yes well i i had been a student here a
long time ago and lived in a
tiny
basement one room flat much smaller than
this studio is um and uh charles lived
upstairs with his his sister and
girlfriend and they invited me up for
drinks one day and they pretty much
adopted me
for my year abroad um and we went to
their parents home in cambridge and to
norfolk for for a holiday and um they so
they really made england feel like a
home uh and i always was
always my ambition to return with a
non-student's budget
to england
and so the chance came in 2010
and moved back here
and charles had just spun talk talk out
from carphone warehouse
and so i guess you can't be ceo of two
publicly traded businesses so he became
chairman of both and ceo of neither
and began thinking a bit more as an
investor and
we got to talking and thinking what's
the
next
big business that opportunity that we we
could leverage his experience in
reputation in retail
but we wanted something that amazon
wasn't so much a threat to
as electronics
online felt like a real threat
to that industry segment and we thought
food and beverage has got to be
a segment that's a bit more protected
from the online world
you kind of have to show this is before
delivery kind of blew up you kind of
have to show up and and and eat your
food where it's prepared more um so we
thought that that would protect uh you
from
the online competitive world and but we
didn't know anything about food and
beverage neither of us did um and so we
went looking for a great
concept that wasn't in the uk that we
thought could bring that expertise we
could bring the
kind of operational uk property
knowledge and hiring practices and
market knowledge and partner with
someone who would bring that food and
beverage experience into the into the
proposition we talked to so many u.s
concepts that weren't here
and eventually kind of collided with the
morel family there actually are five
brothers
and their mom and dad so there's seven
in the family
but five brothers who are the five guys
who founded the business
and they were looking to go
global having pretty much allocated the
u.s amongst their franchisees
how many so how many other concepts do
you think you looked at and was there
any near misses was there any that you
thought you know what maybe any other
concepts that you nearly committed your
your life to yeah so um we talked with a
lot of different concepts and um still
in contact with a lot of those uh those
concepts um and some of them have been
really helpful in terms of um building
the five guys business here so you know
if you can use
insight from another concept that maybe
isn't a competitor isn't here um that
can be really helpful and some of those
still may may come to play um
then why five guys
well i think it starts with the product
um you know it's it's such a simple
fantastic product you know it's just
burgers you know the menu is like
shockingly stark i mean it is burgers
and fries and that's it
um and but it you know when you when you
take a bite of a five guys burger when
you when you when you have fries that
are cooked exactly right
it is it's magical i mean it's and it's
fantastic it's a world world-beating
product and
that was that was i think you know
there's so many concepts have had gone
like broad you know like um you know
there's so many concepts in america like
you can get everything in the in the
menus like a bible and you know you kind
of flip through the section you're like
how can they possibly be preparing
repairing all this stuff at the top of
the game and um and five guys was going
you know completely against that which
was you know everybody told the morel
family you know you have to have a salad
if you're gonna you know be successful
you have to have you know chicken you
know you can't just have a burger on
your menu and they're like
when we add other stuff to our menu it
just
like
blows our mind we don't we lose focus on
making a great burger and so i think
part of their genius has been
focus you know we're going to do just
one thing and do it really well
i mean that was the thesis for the
founding of the business was if you're
going to have your mom over and and make
make burgers you know what would you do
you would buy the highest quality
ingredients you possibly can you'd make
everything fresh um
that was i think the morels were so far
ahead of their time when they founded
the business in 1986 because there's
literally not a freezer
in
the five guys equipment infrastructure
everything is obsessively fresh
and right before the we we signed the
joint venture to bring them here there
was a study done that said the number
one criteria that anyone across the uk
looked for in determining where you were
going to eat was was the freshness of
the food
and whether it was white tablecloth or
at a fast food place it didn't matter
that was the most important criteria and
that was like the morales thesis they
you know not everything had to be
freshly prepared that day or it went um
it's interesting because conceivably
it seems to me like they were very much
at the right place at the right time
there was this macro change in public
perception and awareness around food and
what's going into food
organic and vegan all these kinds of
these conversations around food started
to emerge which seems to have hurt a lot
of big brands um in a very uh
fatal way whether it's in
the sugar based fizzy drink industry or
whether it's in the fast food industry
um it's conceivable that the world could
have gone another way maybe we could
have doubled down on liking
even faster food that was has more crap
in it right yes um so i just i just
wonder how important you think timing
was in in their thesis catching public
that sort of public wave coming into
shore no i think that's i think that's
very i think you're very right about
that you know the the our fries have
three ingredients in it potatoes the
peanut oil we cook it in and a dash of
salt
some of our competitors you know have
like 16 19 ingredients in their fries
like
what do you
what else could there be in in fries you
know so from our perspective our you
know our fries start as potatoes in the
beginning of the day they're hand washed
hand-cut
and then twice cooked to a very specific
standard
and you know just keeping it again just
keeping it simple um and i think i think
it's very much
um i think they
they position themselves in front of a
tidal wave without without knowing it um
and that that trend of freshness um i
think was a huge um a huge win for the
family i think the other thing that they
did which was
very early on trend even early from when
we found it here in the uk was
customization
and having something exactly the way
that you want it
we have 15 free toppings which means
that you can have every burger 250 000
ways just by the combinations of those
those toppings
and everything is made by hand just for
you we don't cook anything until stephen
walks in and says you know this is the
burger that i want um now the
challenging thing is is that as soon as
you've placed your order
there's 249 999 wrong ways to make your
burger um so the customer one of the one
aspect of customer service is getting
that right the first time um but
customization was new i think i mean in
america you know it goes back to harry
met sally and the way she ordered her
salad in the you know in the restaurant
um you know is um you know
an example of how americans want things
just the way they want them um but i
think that's been a newer thing to
europe you know they like the chef
should know you know chef tell me how i
should order this um and saying no no
it should be exactly the way you want it
um and i think that trend is the
certainly the millennials are very much
onto that you know i want it exactly the
way that i want it and five guys is
really ready for that the whole machine
is like um
uh
i liken it to putting a a ferrari engine
on top of an ox cart and then racing it
around a track so we're very old school
very analog in our
product in our production it's very
manual um everything's handmade
and yet we can do
you know a 4 000 pound hour
out of uh you know of oxford circus
making
you know burgers and fries um you'll see
kind of 25 30 people running around
madly behind an open kitchen
making your food i think that was the
other secret because
five guys doesn't advertise so there
literally is no way for us to tell
someone who doesn't know five guys what
we're about or you know what makes us
different or special um we're entirely
relying on someone walking into the
restaurant
seeing how the food is prepared tasting
a great burger and fry and then telling
their their neighbors or their friends
you know hey look you've gotta you gotta
try this um so having an open kitchen
where you can see
that freshness and the customization i
think has been part of the um success of
the business it's almost like there's a
set of really strong values underpinning
the business and the business has been
reverse engineered maybe not even
reverse engineered because when it's the
case of a founding family still running
it i'm sure it all comes sort of
intuitively to them but and so in
hindsight we look at it and go that's
the point of genius that's the point of
genius but it all comes from these
underlying values one of those is about
the freshness of the ingredients and all
being very real so of course the kitchen
would be open right because you've got
nothing to hide yes but in hindsight you
go well you know that's that's genius
well no
it would be strange to hide away the
kitchen in such a context but um that
that particular point about the kitchen
being open at five guys is very
different from all the other fast food
restaurants that came before five guys
that dominated the high street where
you'd order the burger and then
something would go on in the back and
then you'd get this thing wrapped up
given to you yes
i've also seen this trend with all these
fast salad outlets where they put all of
the vegetables the carrots and the
the cucumbers on show in front of you as
if to say these are the carrots that are
going to go into your salad yes and it's
small you don't really you don't think
about it as a customer that much but
somewhere subconsciously it really
really matters right yeah no i mean i
think you know part of the the original
founding of the business um jerry
morrell picked a very obscure location
and said look if we can make this
location work we know we have something
it almost was like a speakeasy um you
know we're like you know knock three
times and you know someone will open the
slide window and you know you give the
secret word and then you come in and so
five guys kind of had a little bit of
that kind of
coolness factor of like hey let me tell
you about five guys it's amazing and you
know maybe you haven't heard of it
certainly haven't seen it on tv or on
the radio but it's amazing and if you
you know come find out so you know when
barack obama left the white house in his
limo to go pick up five guys and for his
office you know that was you know a
great example of how of course you know
everybody knows who he is and that's
kind of like a megaphone but that's how
five guys was discovered that's how five
guys built its business was
one recommendation at a time
and i can remember covent garden was the
very first five guys outside of the u.s
and
we'd spent a lot of money
paying for the bar that was there to
leave
and then building the first five guys
and uh the
we were quite nervous we were well into
five figures seven figures for you know
for the new for the first store and um
the night before opening we were like
what happens if nobody comes and jerry
morell laughed and said you know look
you've picked a good location someone's
going to walk by here and
they'll walk in we'll make them a great
burger and they'll tell their neighbors
and it'll be fine and of course there
was a queue at 4 00 a.m in the morning
and there was a queue around the
building for you know the first two
years that the business was open until
we opened up more five guys around there
because people had tried it in america
including me i tried it and i think i
tried it in america before i tried it
here i'm 99 sure that i tried on my way
to coachella one year or something but
and then when it came here i was like oh
that's that amazing burger place from
america is that why there was a key
around the corner when you were working
there actually is a burger blogger
community right this global okay and
everybody talks about burgers and you
know it's one of those
very um articulate communities that and
there's a lot of debate about who has
the best burger and why it's the best
burger and five guys is in that debate
in that mix and so we're really
fortunate for that um and and actually
when charles and i were were
thinking about who to do business with
it really was when you know when charles
flew over and went to five guys in
manhattan was like this is fanta the
product's fantastic
one thing that we did really differently
in the uk
was the property approach
we thought the product was
it was a category winner it was the best
that we had that we could find but
it was positioned from a property
perspective and you know mostly in strip
centers and in kind of b locations in
america and we thought let's give it the
property
presence that it deserves and i think
that positioning was a really important
distinction that we made richard collier
who runs our property has done a
fantastic job of picking the flagship
locations to say
there isn't a better premium burger than
five guys and we're gonna make sure that
you discover us partly because of where
we are so you chose aspirational
locations because you wanted to make the
brand
aspirational essentially
well we knew that we weren't going to be
advertising so
you know if you can't tell people about
who you are
you have to rely upon the footfall and
that which essentially becomes a word of
mouth accelerator
so if you have a lot of people walking
by your store some will make the
decision to come in and then that larger
group who comes in then kind of tells
everybody else and and that's really the
way the business grew and worked you
know you have this you have this rule
where you don't do advertising
has there ever been a time where you
thought [ __ ] i just want to just run a
little facebook ad you know the pandemic
comes around things start changing in
the world you think [ __ ] i just wanna
you know i know you joined some of the
delivery um services which was a which
was a big big decision for the uk yes
because the us hadn't done that
previously that's right but in those
moments do you not think [ __ ] i just
want to run a little
it's real tempting isn't it i mean you
know when you think about the dashboard
that most
food and beverage executives have you
know you have an advertising dial that
you can crank you know you can choose
the quality of your messaging and the
budget that you put in and the way that
you spend it and all those dials are
gone and off the off the table so you
know it does focus you on the things
that you can do which is
making great burgers and fries hiring
people who are passionate about it you
know kind of back to the whole people
thing
the people who are in the store make
such a difference um you know food
fundamentally is about passion we all
have you know you you're you remember
the great food experiences that you've
had you talk about them and it becomes
part of your if you're on holiday having
great food is part of that experience
and um having a passion about food is so
important and and
having you know i'm responsible for 225
restaurants now um and 8 600 people a
day get up and put on a red shirt and go
into work into five guys and whether
those people who are actually
shaking fries and grilling burgers care
about the product that they're making
the food that they're that they're
cooking
that's all the difference because all we
have is the customer eating a great
product it can't be good right if a
customer takes a bite of a burger and
goes huh that's really good
that doesn't move the dial nothing
happens it has to be that's [ __ ]
fantastic you know i'm going to go tell
somebody who else
who do i know who likes good food i'm
going to tell them
about a burger or a fries you know the
fries at five guys it has to be that
level good and you only get that level
good with people who pour their passion
and their care into the food that
they're preparing and having that many
people care about about
burgers and fries is the you know i
think the what makes us successful you
know that that sort of psychological
device that's making people want to tell
their friends do you spend much time
thinking about exactly why that is like
what is the why would i care if i've had
a great burger why would i care
psychologically to tell my best mate
about that burger what is it doing for
me
that's next level thinking stephen
and and actually is the i
one thing we have been able to do is to
encourage the morels to
widen their thinking a bit um and
delivery was a great example of that
where um they opened up a store near the
pentagon and a general called up jerry
and said like a thousand burgers at you
know noon and uh you know jerry bought a
big sign and hung it up no delivery and
put it on the side of the building um
and you know the thesis was right which
is that our burgers and fries taste best
right off the grill you know it's the
best food experience you can get
but we convinced him that
actually it wasn't just your cheap local
you know
guy who was delivering food it was
actually really high quality food and
more and more people were actually
looking for
really good food delivered if you could
come and try it here yeah yeah from
delivery yeah yeah absolutely before it
went before it went to america for sure
um but we convinced them that all of the
better restaurant concepts were were
actually heading towards delivery
and so gosh five six years ago now we we
started we launched delivery in the in
the uk and it really worked
it kind of became about 20 of our sales
and they saw that of course it's not as
good as right off the grill but it
actually is a good product and people
like it and it and it can work and if
you work with your delivery and you have
a commitment from your delivery partner
to take care of the food as it's
transported to the customer it can
really work and we did a lot of stuff
like you know telling people to you know
turn your oven on 200 pop the fries in
for about you know just a couple minutes
it'll really you know
liven them up before you eat them
so
they saw that it worked here and they
picked it up and of course during the
pandemic it was our lifeblood um you
know it would have been a very different
journey um if there hadn't been delivery
um in the system but we've been able to
convince the morels that some of those
things that were were rules of the brand
before
can actually be good for the brand and
can work and delivery was a good example
of that i guess that's important because
the world is changing so like stubborn
values are really good to some extent
but in a changing world
um it's almost a bit like the bible you
have to be able to look at the thing
again and go huh
yes maybe
you know so indeed indeed
and actually in the morels defense you
know they've they've become successful
who they are
is saying no to change you know when
everybody told them they should do a
chicken sandwich everybody told them
they should do a salad they were like no
no it's too complicated we take our eye
off the ball and the kind of core of
what we do um and helping them to just
to discern that delivery actually is
okay you can be the best
burger being delivered because it
doesn't compromise on their on their
values
those core values of serving food that
your mother would love basically exactly
right so they're willing to innovate but
with i guess they're not compromising on
their values then because those core
values are still there but now it's just
about distributions changing a little
bit well you mean you have a customer
who wants a great burger and they happen
to be watching the football match and
they're like i am not leaving my chair
right i'm watching the football match
and but i want the best burger i can
possibly get
so that customer you can still reach and
and you can give them a really good
product
when you think about the incumbents then
those we'll talk about just the burger
incumbents that were there in the let's
say in the european market before five
guys arrived
why do you think now from everything
you've learned that incumbents
often fall
what is it
gosh
well you know i i i
all i can say is that i think part of it
is
the
the most enduring
concepts will survive um and i think if
you look at five guys you know we five
guys wasn't successful because we put a
slice of avocado you know on a burger so
it wasn't there was nothing trendy about
five guys you know the the kind of the
15 toppings that you know you can put on
a burger whether it's you know grilled
onions or mushrooms or cheese and you
know lettuce tomatoes
fresh is trendy
uh yeah
it it it is trendy but i can't imagine
it ever going out of trend i mean you
you know
yes
i know there are restaurant concepts
where you walk into their kitchen and
there's little like a bank of of
microwaves and they like kind of pull
this stuff out and you pop them in the
microwaves and i mean you know i can't
imagine that anyone would ever go let's
go back to that you know i mean
i think i think fresh is is now
a
an enduring expectation across price
points i mean if you can have you know a
you know a five guys that's incredibly
obsessively fresh you know why would you
not if you could
one of the things that i sometimes think
about why incumbents fall is that um
quality and attention to detail
declines as growth increases so the more
locations we have
quality i can see from your face but
this is
but obviously i think about you know i
won't name names mcdonald's but i um
i just think
you know the more locations you have
especially this underlying franchise
model will really ultimately hurt the
quality of the product and if it hurts
my quality going back to what you said
if i have a bad burger in milton keynes
i'm less likely to go into mcdonald's in
thailand yes so
i mean you know it's funny i mean
mcdonald's i would say is actually a
really strong competitor i mean
they they
they give you what they say on the 10.
is it declining i don't know the numbers
but is that i know you're not you're not
trying to slag anyone off here but is
my thesis is those those businesses are
in decline because there's been this new
wave of like fresh
and you know
almost all of our customers also go to
mcdonald's um and you know
if you if you look at the frequency of
five guys you know mcdonald's has a huge
frequency you know eight times or more a
year which actually ends up being you
know people go there a lot um and five
guys frequency is much lower than that
and and you know it's five guys is a
treat you know it's not something um you
know like a competitor of mine that i
think very highly of you know prett's
done an amazing job uh with who they are
you can go to pret pretty much every day
right and you know the subscription
coffee stuff you know all that kind of
you know stuff works on a routine basis
you can't go to five guys every day i
mean i i go to five guys you know you're
pretty close to it but um you eat a
burger that you know that kind of
frequently but um you know most of the
customers are are going you know a
couple times a year um so
it from a frequency perspective i think
um you know that's what makes five guys
a treat and special so on that point
about um the incumbents and what makes
them fall
and scale being one of those key factors
how do you how do you guard against that
you know you've got 250 225 locations
you said in europe that you're managing
yes um
how do you stop the 226th location
you know getting a little bit sloppy and
complacent and then serving bad burgers
yeah gosh david that you know the the
that was my primary concern when i you
know i was
charles and i structured the joint
venture together we you know we hired
the first employees you know and opened
the first restaurant and you know it had
such
amazing momentum you know it's kind of
this explosion of five guys and it was
you know really you know fun to be a
part of it in my the the kind of thing
that keeps you up is okay we're gonna
grow this business you know as fast as
we can because we know we have something
how are we going to keep
the intensity and the energy and the in
the passion
that we see in the store
in come and garden how do we make sure
that every one of these restaurants has
that kind of that was the
the most that covent garden location
sold more than any in the world
when it launched it did yeah by far i
mean
we underwrote it for like a five and a
half year payback it paid back in two
years i mean it was
just a phenomenal uh success
um
but yeah i mean the thing that kept me
up at night was you know how can we make
sure that you know we open up in milton
keynes we open up in um you know um the
smallest you know we're we're gonna open
up a store in st andrews you know how do
we make sure that that those stores have
people who are absolutely passionate
about burgers and fries and taking care
of hungry customers um and that i will
say
has been one of the biggest surprises of
my uh tenure is in this business is that
it's we've actually gotten better
and
the key to that is
hiring
very talented professionals and trusting
them um and you know
my personal style is a very hands-off
style of management i mean if you expect
me to micromanage you i've we've gotten
off in is the wrong place is the wrong
fit you know
we hire professionals who are really
good at what they do and let them do
their job
and finding those people who are
absolutely
operators i i'd say the other bit is
that we are very operations led um i was
a banker before it before this but i'm
fully qualified in a five guys kitchen
so i can do every task that you see in
you know making a making burgers and
fries i'm certified to do that
and people who are much better at it
than i am could do it much faster than i
can
but if you have any credibility in the
business you have to be operationally
capable
and hiring operationally capable people
who are
really good at identifying and
qualifying those people who can run a
store and bring that passion into a
store that's been the the secret of the
of the the growth of the business um
because
having that kind of commitment from the
person who's showing up and running a
shift that's what that's what makes this
restaurant successful
going back to that point about values i
i would imagine that you know from
speaking to actually sports teams and
speaking to the players in those
successful sports teams whether it's the
manchester united players that were
under sir alex ferguson for 20 odd years
and they they said something to me which
is really interesting and i never forgot
ria ferdinand said to me he said how
many times do you think sir alex
ferguson came into the training ground
changing room i said i don't know
you tell me he goes twice in 26 years
and i go why and he goes well the
culture was in there so he didn't need
to come in
and it spoke and then he told me about
when he moved to another football club
and in that same training ground
changing room they're all bickering and
talking about how much they're being
paid and like slagging things off
whereas sir alex ferguson never needed
to walk into that room because the
culture was already in there and it made
me think about how
you know to keep the specialness of what
made you successful at one location when
you have 225 those values and that
culture must be so strong so if i'm if
i'm starting at five guys in a
management position today what are you
saying to me to turn me into a five guys
disciple well i mean i guess the we do
actually have values that we identify
with inside the business and
hiring right is
essential i mean there's so many
talented food and beverage professionals
who are really good at their job but who
are a terrible fit for us
and so being able to find those human
beings who
work
in a five guys so a general manager
works in the restaurant with customers
with crew making burgers and fries
taking resolving problems and issues
there's not a laptop job and a five guys
um so someone who's looking for kind of
you know kind of ice skate above things
and you know not really getting your
hands dirty that's not the right fit for
us so i guess the first thing we did was
when we opened up nobody knew who five
guys were so we had to beg people to
work for us um and of course that that's
always a a mistake um we hired a lot of
the wrong people and you have a lot of
churn early on trying to find what that
right fit is um and so i remember it was
a really important decision we made
where we're essentially going to invert
the equation
and we said you know five guys is a
really hard job
and it is probably not for you
and then kind of be quiet
and look for the look for the
the woman or the guy who kind of raised
their hand and said that kind of sounds
good to me um and so
having the kind of negative sell on
working at five guys i think was a
really important distinction that we
made but once you get into five guys we
have five values that that we build our
business on um and that's integrity um
you can't once you lose your integrity
everything else is easy um so having
integrity in how you lead
being competitive um and you know
wanting to win and going after
the business being enthusiastic having
passion and positivity and looking for
the solution
family oriented taking care of people
having a sense about
the human beings who are on your crew
and the hungry people who are coming
into your store and treating them like
family then getting it done
not over complicating it our businesses
have you know our menu simple our
business is simple but it's really hard
but making sure that you have a very
much results oriented
focus as a manager and we actually train
and teach those values and when you look
at the pandemic and how five guys
comparatively surfed through the
pandemic it was
because we
taught those values and we all absorbed
those values into how we thought and
then
when you know you had to be agile and
nimble and flexible you knew what what
the what the objective of the business
was and
all the managers just
beautifully adjusted their business to
reflect the opportunities that they
could take
how um how do you go about instilling
those values in team members um beyond
beyond the day when they're hired is
there is there certain things you're
doing every quarter is there daily
emails like what is what are the touch
points where you're using them as an
opportunity to say this is who we are by
the way yeah well i think the first
thing um was a a
card from uh dec that you played was we
we launched an app um right
like within a week of the pandemic
falling we had been planning to have an
uh an employee-oriented app um but we
launched the app um right when the
pandemic struck we're like we have to be
able to communicate because we were none
of us knew what was happening and being
able to be in direct touch with every
human being in the business was
such a um a great tool um and we
immediately had like
massive down i mean it was it was
universally kind of accepted as a way to
communicate with inside the company and
it allowed so i was recording something
pretty much every day to say you know
here's what's going on here's what the
rules are here's why it's going to be
safe to come to work here's how we're
going to protect you and your family and
the crew and and the customers in this
environment
and being able to have that direct line
of communication to the whole company
was really powerful kind of cut through
a lot of the the fear and um and
uncertainty about it one um two is that
we we've now we're now investing
massively in learning and development um
we 75 of our managers are promoted
internally um so these are people who
have joined us we have people who have
joined this crew and gone on to be
district managers area managers now so
that kind of career opportunity um is
fantastic so if you're ambitious if
you're
have you know career goals come to five
guys because we're growing and we need
your talent to to grow the business so
being able to
first of all we know that that career
internal development is kind of the best
path to um to to growing inside of five
guys and having new leaders for all the
restaurants that we're opening we've got
to invest in the young people who are
joining five guys
and teaching them not just burgers and
fries but how to manage
how to manage people um you know there's
so many different kinds of people that
it takes to make a restaurant work
how you communicate with one crew member
may be very different from how you
communicate and motivate with another
one and giving our managers tools for
how to connect with all different kinds
of people
who work for them is you know an
important investment that we make before
the pandemic happened um i think i said
a lot on this in this podcast and just
generally that my single biggest
learning being a young entrepreneur
starting in business and then making all
the mistakes and then getting a little
bit more mature was the importance of
talent and i always say that by
definition of the word company the
definition of the word company means
group of people took me too long to
figure that out because when i started i
was 20 years old you know you just hire
your mate here
18 years old i started my first
companies hired you know my friend here
i met someone at rap event i was like
you can be my marketing director went
into prada met and other guys that you
can be the head of our account it was
just that kind of whoever was willing
right right
great people
exactly probably who i needed at that
phase but for the next phase you need to
um i learned that you need a different
caliber of person and really i should
have been a bit more ambitious from the
jump if i'm being completely honest
um and so now i reflect on it and think
damn in fact every company is just a
recruitment business at its core like if
i had hired steve jobs i would have
and bound them with the right culture
and values yeah i would have had an
apple right i would have made an apple
how important do you think it is um
to hire the best people and how how do
you go about that what is the
the strategy
yeah well first of all i think we had
the benefit of seeing the success of
five guys in the u.s so charles and i
had a conviction
that even before we opened the first
store of course we were nervous when we
opened it but that we we thought we had
a tiger by the tail because we thought
the product was fantastic
so
we were able to assemble people who were
proven to be really good at what they
did from the outset and kind of like
across the board in the senior
management team so julie spear who's my
head of operations unbelievable we would
we wouldn't be where we are without her
richard collier who's head of property i
mean he opened up 2 400 stores for
carphone warehouse all across europe
really
established professional those two are
were essential we would never be where
we are without those two individuals but
then
kind of driving that all the way down to
the you know the the the first crew
person who you hire in a new and for a
new store
hugely important because they're
actually gonna be making the burger and
fry for for the customer who walks in
there and you know i think that you know
it's probably an urban myth but the
shackleton story about you know putting
an ad in the paper for his you know
south uh
south pole expedition you know it's
gonna be dangerous and risky we'll
probably you know we may not come back
alive but if we do there'll be glory
that kind of negative cell
i think was a critical point for us
where you know five guys is a really
hard job huge expectation physically
demanding job
it's not for everybody and and you know
stating that being confident enough to
say
look you know
you're a very talented human you know
professional in food and beverage but
you're just not the right fit for us and
being the confidence to say no in that
regard that was hard but i think that
was a real turning point um in the
business for us what about firing people
that's the worst part of the business um
really hard you know i mean it's um you
know
if you get it wrong it's so painful you
know these are people who you know who
are human beings
and if the jobs either outgrown them
or they were the wrong cultural fit
it's really obviously it's hard for them
but i mean it's def it's really it's
it's a soul-crushing moment which makes
it that much more important to hire
right and in the interview for culture
you know but when when an interview
finally gets to my level
i am 100 focused on culture i mean the
the whole qualification of their
professional skills has been addressed
by the time they get to me and i am
solely focused on are you a good
cultural fit um are you the kind of
person who you know obviously is good at
what you do but are you going to be when
we're in the trenches and when the the
chips are down and we have to make the
hard calls are you going to
value the the same things that i will
and that we do as a company um to make
your decisions what is your philosophy
though for moving people and you have a
clear philosophy around hiring people
what is the philosophy for moving people
on because i've made this is again one
of my other biggest mistakes in my
professional career was allowing people
who are clearly not right fit to kind of
overstay their uh journey with my
company
i just wish sometimes that i had because
the net damage of that when you your gut
tells you this isn't this is not the
right person yeah but maybe for whatever
reasons emotional reasons you don't act
fast enough is so severe
yeah well you know i mean i i first of
all i think i think you can't you have
to make the decision that's best for the
business um and the in in realizing that
this business is bigger than any of us
um including me um you know i can be i'm
i'm hired and fired by by my board um
you know charles and the morels can
decide any day that i'm not the right
guy to lead the business going forward
and certainly at the executive level to
me
my expectation is that everyone should
have that expectation it's a privilege
to have the jobs that we do it's not a
right um and if if there's a if there's
a tough decision to be made
making it clearly cleanly um and
directly is the best thing and there's
no reason to be
um
negative about it you have to be but you
do have to be very direct about it um
and quick um
quick is really important in in my book
you know there is a bit of a difference
between the uk and the u.s um you know
the u.s has a um favors that quick side
of things and i think i probably fall
into that category and that can be a
challenge in an environment where
there's like you know what about a
six-month garden leave yeah i'm like
what is it i'm not sure what a garden i
went the other way so i launched a
business here then we took it to america
and i'm like what two week notice period
everyone has a two week notes but what
the hell is this yeah and it's really
just a box and you know please you
probably should leave now uh in america
more than more than not it feels like um
but i think once you've made that
decision
it's you can't move soon enough um
because and it's rare
that someone is that you would consider
to say i really don't think they're
right for the job and that that person
kind of recovers to being a superstar
right that almost never happens so
if you do have that i'm not sure that
i'm not sure this person's right for the
business either from a talent
perspective or from a cultural fit
perspective you know it's probably i
mean i think you need to listen to that
urge because it's probably right and
actually it's a favor to that human
being as well because they're gonna
whether it's talent or if it's um you
know a cultural fit
there may be a fantastic opportunity
elsewhere for them and all you're doing
is holding them in a you're holding them
back professionally because they're
never going to fly in your organization
but they might in another court in
another culture
so i know it never feels like that um to
say you know look i'm doing you a favor
by you know telling you that you you
know not to work here anymore um but if
you know someone's not going to be
successful in your business it is best
for everybody to do that quickly and as
soon as you can actually
how important have you
realized it to be in the five guys
business and
for the success of a five guys brand to
have a real high attention to detail and
to sweat the small stuff because a lot
of businesses don't sweat the small
stuff they kind of see it as being petty
or not mattering and they kind of focus
more on like the big decisions they make
but
you know what's your sort of philosophy
towards the small stuff
um
well first of all i think being
operationally focused is something that
defines your business um and for us so
our details are the standards for
cooking burgers and fries and you can
never
focus on that enough um you can and you
know if you're not actually cooking
burgers and fries you better be
supporting someone who is in the
business so that that kind of
um
horrible disconnection that you can
sometimes have of a head office people
who call it the head office we call it
the back office
from the actual business
um is is you know to me is the death
knoll for uh you know for for certainly
for a food and beverage business um so
having that connectivity to the detail
of um of the the purpose of our business
which is feeding hungry customers uh is
is to me is essential
now
from a detailed perspective i don't want
to get into the details of my i.t guy or
my marketing team or the property team
you know
i've hired people who are fantastic at
that and i don't want to be into the
details i can't be into the details of
each of those professional expertise
that you hire for you have to hire
talent and let them do their um their
professional expertise
but how do you check that you know if
something say something in one of your
stores and say like we mentioned milton
keynes so let's just keep focusing on
that um
in milton keynes if standards have
dropped because of the leadership there
how are you checking that
those standards are staying high yeah so
we mystery shop every store twice a week
okay and and we put the money that we
would typically that other brands would
spend on advertising we spend an
incentive compensation for crew so we
pay out millions and millions of pounds
of incentive compensation to crew to be
the to be the best of the best
and we grade so the mystery shop looks
like 120
points of what of what's important from
a burgers and fries perspective from a
cleanliness perspective from a customer
service perspective
and the top rated
shops that have
that perform get paid incentive
compensate meaningful incentive
compensation um so i'd say that com back
to the competitiveness everybody wants
to get paid everybody wants to compete
for that excellence and to be recognized
for that um so mystery shopping i think
is a is a fantastic way of
ensuring that we're all focused on the
same thing and if you find a location is
continually ranking at the bottom of
that mystery shopping scoreboard what
what are the next steps of action yeah
well i mean you know the first question
is in store leadership you know who's
who's leading the store are they the
right person do they have the right
orientation do they have the right
values um are there are they trained
enough to do their job well um so um you
know we have a very flat organization
where you go from general manager to
district manager
area manager and then you know basically
the top of the business um so it's it's
pretty pretty quick um and and i do
what's called a mid-year review i'm
actually missing a couple to be on your
on your on your podcast today uh but we
have every gm stand and present their
stores performance once a year in june
july august in that time frame
and so i get a view of the in-store
leadership you know who is that human
being who's in charge of that store what
do they have to say about the results
that they've delivered both from a
financial perspective most of all from a
perform from a customer service
perspective and a quality perspective so
you kind of get a direct view into who
is that human being who's running the
store one of the things that's happened
over the last couple of years is this
this pandemic it's been this very
tectonic shift um in many industries but
there are a few industries that have
been affected more than like the high
street and retail and food and beverage
there's been real tectonic shifts in
technology and footfall and all of these
things um as the ceo of a business
that's gone through such chaos how do
you maintain your own personal
calm within all of that chaos because it
is just never ending we were talking
before we start recording you've gone
from a pandemic to inflation issues to
this sort of great resignation and uh
you know talent crisis as they're
talking about all of these things
happening at once you're a human being
in the heart of that
how do you enjoy your life and
keep
calm and you know
not annoy your partner or whatever
um yeah i'm sure i do all those things
i'm sure i'm sure i don't keep calm all
the time
and that's okay
you know i think
just as we in the business try to keep
things simple um focus on burgers and
fries um i think there's
keeping focused on just a few things and
picking the couple of dials that that
will
determine whether you
survive whether you live or die
whether you win or lose
and
hopefully picking those right things to
focus on
i think is
the way i try and and
manage myself as a ceo um you know i
think
it's interesting you know the the
moments that i
consider to be the most intense and the
most rewarding
as a as a leader
are the human ones where
because i'm ceo
people have to explain what's going on
in their lives
and those moments are just rich gold for
me as a human being where someone comes
to me and says you know i have i've got
a parent who's suffering from dementia i
have to you know have to spend some time
looking after that and um or you know i
i've i've had a loss and i've got to
figure out um you know how to manage
that that loss and and those human
connection points
are um
are and actually that kind of feeds back
into our family value um you know where
we
and as a ceo i have my a smaller
direct report community that i have to
take care of those human beings and my
my view is that if i can take care of
those human beings they'll they'll do
their job and take care of of their
human being so recognizing that it's not
you know it's not all dollars and pounds
and and pence it's not all um you know
kpis that you can manage it's not
quarterly earnings it's the human beings
and if you focus on them
particularly on the vulnerable moments
when they're most
um upset when they're most um at risk um
and being able to say yeah you know
take a week take them you know what what
you need
as a human being is important for the
business because i need you i need your
professional acumen but i need it
focused so
being being sure that they're all right
in those moments i think is uh um
gives me
the satisfaction that i'm looking for
from the job of of chief exec
um my dad was a psychiatrist
um and you know was obviously clearly
focused on mental health and well-being
and you know from a chemical perspective
um and you know realizing that whatever
whatever
chemical i mean obviously i'm sure he
did important work in that regard um but
you can
at work you have the ability to either
build up or tear down
someone's mental health and being able
to provide an environment where
someone's mental health is
protected and
perhaps even tended to
i think is a is a powerful
um
it's a powerful thing for me as a as a
leader and and and hope
what i see is that that approach
carrying out
throughout the business so that style of
leadership um is you know is is
contagious as a value in the business so
you know
if if someone's in distress
um in in a crew um you know the the
shift will suffer and you have to take
care of that person who's um in distress
um and um understand them and and see
what it takes to build them back up and
to provide them the support and security
to to be effective in their job
what about your mental health when was
your hardest time my hardest time
in your five guys journey yeah well um
i was i went through a very painful
divorce um and
went through something called leave to
remove which i wouldn't wish on my worst
enemy
it's the essentially it's the right to
have your children taken out of the
country
so i had two young children um who
um
the court system approved leave to
remove which allowed my ex to to take my
kids back to america um which was um
incredibly painful um and my whole um
view of myself my definition of who i
was
changed i thought i thought of myself as
a
you know great partner good husband good
father devoted father
you know
i was in politics back in america
was involved in my community and a
church leader and
businessman and i thought you know all
these things are who i am and
essentially all of that was uh you know
a quite a large bonfire of vanities
and that was a real dark dark moment for
me um and there were there were days
when five guys was
the one thing in my life
that was stable and that i could hold on
to and that really pulled me through
a very difficult dark time uh personally
how long did that that process last um
that's part of the uk challenge it took
years um a better part of two years uh
we're in that process um and then um you
know trying to um rebuild those
relationships and thankfully i'm in a an
amazing place with my kids now um and
have um you know
accepted that they
that we have had a more adult
relationship
prematurely but now that they're both at
university
it feels more normal
now and
those are hard fought hard-won
recast relationships
which you know were really important are
important to me
but was i was
the thought that they were at risk
was um
caused just enormous anxiety and and
living with that kind of anxiety and the
personal side having having a place
where um you know things were more
predictable
was um in being able to work in that way
and provide for them um was uh you know
a real
um
yeah really helped me through
when your kids are
essentially taken away to another
country and you you've got this huge
responsibility of running this big
business how do how does that impact
your ability to show up every day
professionally yeah
well i mean it was it was it was really
complex for me because i had a
non-compete back in the us for the
business that i had sold so i couldn't
just relocate back to america and do my
job um so it felt like a huge catch-22
because i had these court-ordered
financial obligations and the only way
that i could really fulfill them was to
keep doing my job here um so
coded financial obligations is in the
separation costs and stuff that you have
to pitch apart yeah exactly um so it
felt like a catch-22 they were allowed
to leave but i had to provide for them
so i had to stay and so it felt like a
um kind of a indentured servant to for a
bit but um you know
being able to um to focus on
um on a
important job that i had actually was
enormously relieving because i knew that
for you know
10 hours a day you know 12 hours a day
whatever whatever it ended up being that
i could actually
do something productive that i knew i
was good at um that made a difference
for them um and that um
was it the the anxiety of of being
separated i i could set aside for a few
you know for those hours in a day and
that was really helpful um it it it
could have absorbed just kind of
overwhelmed me um but work was able to
it was it was a place where i could or i
could escape from that did you see
your motivation fluctuate often when we
have these like pretty substantial life
events there's an initial period where
getting out of bed in the morning is a
little bit more difficult it's almost
like someone is messed with your why
your reason to get out of bed in your
sense of purpose yeah so you always have
to i've learned from my own experiences
that you have to spend a little bit of
time you're almost
faking it
to get to get the drive back if that
makes sense no of course no well you
know i told you i got up at 5 a.m when i
was a kid and practice violin for an
hour before before uh school and what i
mean i was never a great musician but
what i did find was that if you did
something every day
you actually could get better at it
maybe even more than competent
and
i think it was something like that that
just in me you know said you know get
out of bed do the next do the next thing
and
something things will change you will i
called a friend of mine who'd been
through a similar um situation um and he
said you know just keep showing up you
know you know texting my son every day
calling you know every day
being as present as i possibly could um
and you know
obviously it's imperfect um and it's
deeply upsetting i'm sure to them as
well as as well as to me um but doing as
much as you possibly can to be available
and in touch um and and then you just
have to trust um trust something that
it'll be okay
trust something
doesn't just trust life that it will
no i mean you know i i
now we're getting very personal to even
but uh you know i i i believe in a
higher power um i i don't i don't
pretend to understand it um but i think
there's something much more powerful
than i am in the world
and what i will say is that it helped me
to see the world in two camps one are
things that i can't control
and some things that i absolutely can't
control
and if you spend if you allocate your
mental um health and your time on the
things that you can't control
um you can drive yourself to distraction
and eventually madness um so being able
to focus on the things that you can
control um and and realizing that that's
your job um you know your job as a human
is to do the things that you can control
and if you if you you know it's just
it's just arrogance and and um ignorance
to to focus on the things that you can't
control um and so
identify those identifying those two
camps and being at peace with that
accepting that you can't some things you
can't control that's really hard
but it's hugely important
yeah i i was at this festival this
weekend and there was a
i did one-on-one meetings with lots of
people that were in the audience for
three hours and i found myself being
asked over and over again how to deal
with exactly that which is when chaos
arrives in our lives what to do on that
day and people had me recording these
voice notes for them for that day so
when that day comes they just wanted to
be able to play it and what you said
there is exactly what i said which is
there are a small list of things you can
control and on that tough day make a
promise to me that you'll spend 100 of
your mental energy focusing only on
those things because you can't because
obviously yesterday focusing too much on
that tends to lead to depression as i
think the lu sao the philosopher says
focusing too much on tomorrow and the
things that are yet to be in your
control will also cause a lot of anxiety
so really focusing on today i think is
just phenomenal advice in terms of
um a
it's the thing that's most conducive
with a successful outcome but b it's
also the thing that's most conducive
with having a healthy mental
state in total chaos
i think that's absolutely right i mean i
think the other thing is that realizing
that our pr i believe our purpose in
life is human connection um i think
that's why we're here i think we're
we're made to to connect and sometimes
it's you know we're colliding with you
know and
more than connecting but but figuring
out how to connect with other human
beings and i will say you know
that was the making of me as uh uh the
in being able to
to
you know when someone comes into my
office and says you know i've i've lost
my i've lost my partner you know they
passed away you know
way before their time you know
being able to connect with that person
in that moment of loss is
hugely valuable as a company
but hugely meaningful to me as a human
being
and
i wouldn't have been able to do that if
i if i hadn't been through the
loss that i that i had experienced um so
you know it's one of those things where
you end up being grateful for the the
most upsetting things that happen in
your life um because i think they're the
making of you in many ways
because of what you said at the start of
this conversation about that importance
of feeling like you belonged and that's
so it's so evident that that is
um much of the reason you've also been
successful is your you you mean even
from this short conversation we've had
you strike me as a very empathetic
person who's able to connect with others
that moment must have been presumably
even more difficult because your sense
of belonging in that moment was was
taken from you to some degree the family
unit right no for sure that was that was
a yeah that was a defining moment um but
now you know
the thing about
about five guys is that you know we have
these 8 600 people who get up every
morning
and have this shared vision mission to
make great burgers and fries for hungry
customers
and
i get to be a part of that and you know
i get to be a part of this larger
community that that has this the in the
you know winning in business feels
fantastic right i mean it's a real
it's a real high it's a it's a um it's a
drug and it's an addiction and being a
part of a community
that had that that's accomplishing this
thing you know we were the we were the
eighth fastest growing business uh in
2016 i think in the uk and the fastest
growing food and beverage business and
even with that we never met a budget
that i had made so you know we were you
know we were fastest but you know still
behind by by by my mind and um
being it being a part of this community
that shares our our values and that are
all working towards us is is
enormously satisfying and um
and yeah fill something that that you
know has always been empty
some days as ceos we
maybe we're tired or you know
we're in a bad mood or something's off
um we can sometimes not show up as our
best selves
and sometimes when it happens with me i
i regret it so i'll go home and think i
just wish i had i wish i'd handled that
situation differently does that happen
to you a lot where you think
i wish i'd
been in a better mood or i'd slept more
today or something yeah julie tells me
julie my head of ops she comes in and
says yeah you really [ __ ] up that
meeting
but but but actually having um having
somebody who
um you know
to me the the one of the worst things
that can happen
are these um you know emperor has no
clothes where you know where the
where the the most important powerful
person in business has blind spots that
you know everybody knows about and
somehow you you know you work around um
and and that's just
hugely dangerous as a business
and having people who can come into your
office and go john that that was you
know that comment was just way out of
line or really unhelpful you know you
now have people thinking like this is
that what you wanted
so people who can confront
power
with truth and you know to me that that
kind of culture is hugely important to a
company because you can go so wrong
with the emperor has no clothes and
people think god we know this we just
can't tell them to that person how did
you cultivate that
because i imagine a lot of ceos and a
lot of team members that work for a ceo
think ah there's no way i could go to my
ceo and tell them that was wrong or he
shouldn't have said that
or she should have said that i think
publicly owning your [ __ ] um is is
really is really helpful um in that way
you know so showing up at the next
meeting and go hey you know what i said
this the last meeting and that was just
really wrong it was off and
you know i was i was off my game or you
know i didn't think it through and you
know
and it should be the opposite it should
be the opposite of that um and and you
know
showing that you can respond to that
kind of challenge i think is is is
important as a leader and then you give
everybody else permission to do the same
thing you know i mean
you can change your mind you're allowed
to change your mind you're allowed to be
wrong as a fallible human being too um
and and
confessing that it's powerful that
confession there
when i heard when i heard that example
what it actually says to me as well is
that as a ceo you care more about the
correct answer not being right so that
might be confusing as because of the way
i said that
when you come stand in front of your
team members and say you know what in
hindsight i actually got that really
wrong and i i [ __ ] up what you're
actually saying is
my number one thing as john
is to be is to find the right answer not
for me to be correct
yeah and it's like and it's a really
it's really refreshing to hear that
you're in search of truth and the
correct answer not in search of
validating your own um your own opinions
and yourself which as you say creates
that culture of humility where hopefully
others around them will go i'm also
wrong in this situation
exactly business shouldn't be an homage
to an individual right i mean you know
we have we're about perfect burgers and
fries hungry customers clean restaurants
customer service and that's that's
really simple i mean it's not a um and
if
if any of us isn't the right human being
to
fill the function that we're supposed to
be performing you know we all should
raise our hand and say you know
it's probably not me anymore how do
people give um do you have a system in
which people at five guys could give
that are working there in the team could
give critical feedback safely yeah so i
mean we do have kind of like the
scheduled uh annual conversations um
i didn't often uh you know it was kind
of in my you know in my
don't micromanage um you know it was
just kind of like you know people will
come to me if they you know if they need
to and i think that that probably was
wrong um
and you know saying look we're going to
have a dedicated time
and and really
you know i i don't i don't like fill out
a form where you know so you did well in
this and poorly in that you know we
don't i don't do that you know um but i
sit and say you know
let's talk about what worked and what
didn't both from you know chance for you
to tell me
what didn't didn't work but also for us
to talk about what didn't go right you
know and and worked you know this year
for you um and you know what do we do to
fix that you know how do we how do we
make it better um so i think having a
set time to talk about that actually is
a good idea and i've taken that up relax
somewhat reluctantly but now
enthusiastically
you much of this conversation is
centered around um
five guys sort of central philosophy of
really really caring about the customer
and you talked a little bit about how
each store has mystery shoppers that
come in and make sure those standards
are maintained um is your objective now
to push the standards up even further
or is it to maintain the standards
no i i well well first of all i think
you know i'm responsible for germany
france spain portugal uk and in each
market has a little different national
temperament
and figuring out what constitutes good
customer service
is a is a bit of a nuanced thing in each
given market give me an example of the
difference um you know does does someone
want to be checked back on you know so
they're you know someone's sitting there
eating their food you know they're kind
of like one of the things we talk about
is first mover advantage you should have
your head on a swivel looking around for
people who are
looking for a solution to a problem with
their meal um and you i'm sure you've
had that you know we're like you know
i'd like some yeah
like some extra topping or sauce or
something and you can't get anybody's
attention and so teaching someone how to
how to be in tune with a customer who's
looking for help and that's very
culturally uh dependent um someone can
communicate that very differently um in
you know in the different markets one of
the things i've been thinking a lot
about because i had that exact problem
recently was i was in a restaurant it
was very busy and i feel like i spent 15
minutes like trying to get someone's
attention to try and get some ketchup
yes um the food goes cold i'm like you
know and then i start eating it by the
time they've come she really wanted that
ketchup yeah they're really and it's
gone before then i asked for the ketchup
and i've eaten it before the ketchup so
i just have a bowl of ketchup and no
food um and i was thinking i sat there
in this restaurant in
in spain
a week ago and i was thinking if they
just had an ipad on the table i could
have pressed a button and they would
have known and they would have and it
would have helped them because i'm sure
they want to help me they just weren't
aware yeah and i would have got helped
faster have you not
considered implementing more technology
in and
in the place of um
human beings that sounds pretty brutal
but it's just the truth yep no i mean
technology is part of the solution it's
certainly i mean and actually probably
your phone is already there and there's
got to be a way to make yours you know
this communication tool that you already
have in your hand
hooked up to an effective way inside the
restaurant now more and more young
people expect technology to be part of
their
journey um and they're securing of the
things that they want and need but
they're they're also people who are you
know completely opposed to that um you
know we are we are a very analog brand
in that sense um
i think that there is more openness to
technology and there ever has been
before so we did curbside service um
which essentially is like reverse uber
where we can kind of track your car as
it approaches and we can prepare your
food as we see the countdown for your
arrival and so the the kind of perfect
scenario which we often get is where you
drive up and the fries have just come
out of the the fryer and shaken and
salted and ready to go and and it kind
of like comes together beautifully at
the at the right moment so you
absolutely we should use technology to
meet the customer's needs and to address
those people who
want to who prefer technology to and
also we can't be everywhere and be
perfect in every you know in terms of
responsive so yes technology will be a
part of that interaction going forward
somewhat caught between two generations
i imagine because i was in nando's the
other day and the first time they've
told me oh you can just order from the
qr code stuck on the table right and i
imagine my my dad
might not like that experience yeah for
me it was convenient i said perfect
great as not to talk to anybody
typical you know millennial gender but
well
and and we should be able to adapt
for the for the customer um because
they're they're human beings who who
actually view customer service as not
having to speak right i really just want
to stay in my own world and and you know
press a button and and and get exactly
what i want um and you know we should be
responsive to that how much do you think
the the structure and the way that the
business the foundations of the business
in terms of it being a joint venture
with the morales as opposed to a
franchise and generally the philosophy
towards what you're building and how
long that sort of time horizon is has
impacted the product and therefore the
customer and therefore the success
of the company well i mean
of course my experience is incredibly
biased because all i've ever known is
the company owned model um and so the
franchise model is genius and it really
works and there's a powerful power to it
and you can become really strong as a
franchise and franchised business um
it's really worked well for us um you
know we wrote you know whenever you
whenever you form a company and whenever
you form a joint venture you kind of
have all these rules and you know
governance and how to make decisions and
bro we've never even
referred to it once over the past 12
years um so you know the having nothing
but building a profitable business has
been fantastic for me
as a chief exec because i knew that my
shareholders were completely aligned um
and we would never have made the
decisions that we did particularly from
a property perspective
without being a joint venture as a
franchisee you wouldn't have paid the
premium to be to buy a ten thousand
square foot property on the
champs-elysees and between the louis
vuitton corporate headquarter and the
abercrombie and fitch global flagship
store um and there's five guys it's
amazing you know it's it's it's probably
the most high profile visible five guys
apart from the one that's in the dubai
mall
so
that property strategy was definitely
influenced by the structure of the deal
taking those high you know high
investment property uh decisions to
reposition the brand um you know as
premium as we could get it and it's
still running like a family business at
its core yeah still making those very
value focused decisions as opposed to
making decisions for the stock market or
the quarterly earnings report is not a
pressure for me at all um you know the
the family meets every tuesday and talks
about the the future of the business
i meet with charles on a monthly basis
to review the property and the pricing
and the positioning of the brand um and
those conversations would be different
with a different structure for sure
because one of the things you said is i
don't have a time horizon which means
you're not trying to build a business
for three years and then jump ship and
get out so you said i don't have a time
horizon i'm going which allows you to
build a really great business
for the long term yeah and that's what
i'm kind of getting at because there'll
be business owners listening to this
that are maybe thinking oh i'll build
for two years then i'll sell it or i'll
build for three years and i'll sell it
but what you alluded to there is that
you'll create a much better business if
you remove that time horizon
it has been for us um you know and
obviously i've been involved in private
equity investments i mean
there certainly is a place for that um
and i'm not saying you can't be
successful in those environments it's
really worked for us to be able to focus
on you know an indefinite time horizon
and doing the right thing today i mean
ultimately private equity wants you to
do the right thing today
and whether it plays out next month next
week next quarter i think the
sometimes the interpretation of the
urgency of the investment window can be
misinterpreted to make
urgent decisions rather than the right
decisions and i think it's up to this to
some degree it's up to the chief exec to
say
wait a minute
you're you're all focused on the wrong
thing just right now we could do this
which is going to make more quarterly
earnings next quarter and i'll make my
budget but the right decision is to
invest in the medium term long term and
here's why so i think it's i think there
is a lot of pressure but to some degree
it's it's that that position of chief
exec where you need to say wait a minute
that's the wrong wrong business decision
and we can
to build a better business be more
successful by thinking not about next
quarter what's the biggest threat to
five guys
biggest threat to five guys um
i think losing focus on the the basics
of burgers and fries thinking that we're
something other than being burgers and
fries um you know that laser focused on
making the best burger you could for
your mom i mean that has got to be at
the center of you know of of who we are
and what we're about treating each other
like family um and
realizing that it's the human beings who
are in the store fundamentally that that
that to me was the biggest inversion
from banking
banking was it felt like to me a very
prima donna-ish business where
very individual
accomplishment
and you could get ultimately get paid
by moving from one shop to another and
taking credit for work you might not
have been 100 percent responsible for
in this business it's all about
reflecting any glory that comes to the
business to the people who are actually
making the burgers and fries taking care
of the business and to me
whenever we
if we were to ever lose focus on burgers
and fries that would be the end of the
business
on a personal level then what is what
makes you happy outside of the
professional stuff outside of five guys
what what is it what are the ingredients
that make you happy
um
it's the connection stuff um the painful
gritty vulnerable connection stuff um
and
um yeah you know i mean
like i tell my kids now you know i mean
i hope that i'm the guy that you call
when something's gone wrong um you know
it's great it's great to get the calls
that you got good grades and that you
you know you got the job you wanted and
things are going well you got a
promotion you know that's wonderful but
i want to be i want to be the call when
something you know some when something
goes wrong when someone breaks up with
you and you know you don't you're i mean
your job doesn't go the way you want to
want it to go you know to me that
connectivity at the vulnerable place
places is the currency that is most
precious to me
it's much the reason why we started this
podcast to be honest because
you know
sometimes being a ceo much of it is
about
well i used to think it was about being
seen as being perfect and
strong
and like you never had any personal
issues yourself i think that's probably
what i what i'd learned about being a
ceo and a leader it was always you know
you've got to be um uh
rock solid but um
the reason why this podcast was called
the diary of a ceo is because ceos are
humans too
successful people are humans too and it
turns out they have all the same
[ __ ] and problems and pain and
personal stuff that everyone else has in
their lives and you've talked about much
of that today if you're if you're if
you're i know this is a question i've
asked a few of my guests recently just i
really enjoyed asking the question but
it's there's somewhat of a pun in it i
guess in this case um if your if your
happiness is a recipe consisting of a
series of ingredients and different
quantities like you know
the five guys fries just being three
ingredients
what would be what are those ingredients
and
is there anything missing
[Music]
well i think vulnerability is the
you know probably the biggest new
ingredient that i've had to mix into
into my life how to
yeah i mean you know i think i think the
being separated from my kids
forced a you know forced me to
re-look at everything
and i think also
um
realizing that i have massive blind
sides that i don't see um and that
i i have convictions about the way i
think in my intentions
but actually there's a huge sea of
unconscious motivations that i that i'm
unaware of and purposefully so right we
we build our our mental defense
constructs to deny
the unconscious motivations but that
actually drive us
um and that's what my my partners helped
me to see that you know that
there's so much that i you know i think
i'm doing something because i'm trying
to be generous
and actually it's not because i'm
working out some anger
and and i don't want to admit that you
know i want to be the good guy right um
and and being able to see that shadow
side of yourself and to acknowledge that
and to and to even embrace that and to
say it's okay that's part of me um and
you know that's really um that's been
the hardest bit for me in the past
couple years but um i think probably the
most um
the most valuable what did you find in
the shadows
oh
gosh all the stuff you don't want to see
about yourself that you're selfish that
you're
um that you
i i think you know i grew up
thinking that i couldn't express
negative emotions you know i couldn't be
angry i couldn't you know i and and but
that goes i mean of course you get angry
all human beings do but and that goes
somewhere
and if you if you stuff it somewhere it
comes out in the worst ways that people
that you love and care about um and in
ways that you're probably that i'm not
even aware of
um so
feeling that that it's okay to
to be angry um is probably you know the
hardest thing for for me i'm i'm i'm
just starting to work on that i don't
pretend to be to be good at it um but
being able to
be if i were to tell
little john growing up
you know something it would be it's okay
to have
all the emotions that you you know that
you have and there's room in the world
for all for you to express them and to
to feel them and to own them and to you
know to
to be part of you it's okay um
and you know
even looking at my kids now trying to
say
you know actually some negative tension
in our relationship is really valuable
um you to be able to see that it's okay
for you to be angry at me me to be angry
at you and to work those out and it's
gonna be okay and that we're gonna be
we're gonna be
um connected
even with that
that's really powerful because they need
to be able to take that into their adult
relationships um and you know else
they'll you know they'll struggle
they'll struggle those places too um and
it'll become that intergenerational
uh
negative baggage that gets passed on so
i'm trying to try to do something
different in that regard that
conversation with um
younger john
about it's okay to be have a full range
of emotions and to be angry
because if you don't
you'll hurt the people you care about
in ways that you don't intend
in ways that you don't understand
and they and they may not understand i
mean you know i'm lucky in my partner
that um you know that she's quite
um attuned she has a she's just
finishing her master's in uh
psychotherapy and so you know being able
to say yeah i mean
i'm i'm getting this from you even
though you don't intend it um let's deal
with it um that's a that's a gift well
you're talking about there as well as
this process of like becoming more
self-aware about yourself because you're
completely right i mean a lot of the
stuff i've been reading recently about
psychology talks about how we actually
have as exactly as you said have this
default to just reinforcing ourselves
reinforcing the way we think and believe
and searching for evidence that confirms
it and confirms the identity we want to
have of ourselves but to become
self-aware is is a very difficult
challenge requires a huge amount of
humility feedback
um uh you know unlearning learning um
what's what has been the the practical
ways that you've gone on that journey to
become more self-aware is it therapy is
it just the feedback from your partner
what is yeah well i mean i think first
go through something really horribly
painful where you have to reconsider
everything um and you know who you are
and to be willing to put those on the
on the table and say you know i thought
i was being a great partner i wasn't um
you know and and being able to
being able to re-define
the givens of who you think you are
that's that's really that's really
painful um and you know you you you come
up with these ways of thinking about
yourself for a reason
and they're typically defense mechanisms
from a very young age so these are not
easy things to to give up
but to me
it was it was
i had to do it or i would lose
connection with everyone that i cared
about
and to me it was it was it's you know
connection is worth it
um and my uh i can remember my
grandmother who was one of the first
ones who taught me to love food i had a
very strange relation have a very
strange relationship with food in that
regard but she um
you know she she was um and late in her
life she was an amazing cook and i could
see the love felt the love she had for
me and the food that she prepared um
and late in life she was in a retirement
home and and uh some health inspector
deemed some of the food had been passed
like its expiry date um she came to me
and she said they were trying to serve
us food that was unfit for human
consumption and we were like oh that's
terrible we'll fix that
but i always worried that i somehow
particularly in a romantic partner
setting was unfit for human consumption
and maybe maybe in my weird isolated
countercultural upbringing there were
skill sets that was
that worked in being a business leader
but
maybe those very things disqualified me
from being successful in a romantic
relationship
and so overcoming and overcoming that
sense of being unfit for human
consumption um in a romantic setting is
uh you know that's hard and was that
causing some some form of self-sabotage
in the romantic context inevitably
inevitably um so um and being able to
and being able to go back and accept the
negative emotions um you know it's not
up to anybody else to express my anger
for me that's up to me um should be up
to me um and i should be able to
spontaneously experience that in real
time and express that in appropriate
levels
that's that's uh that's my to-do list
have you been too much of a nice guy
so maybe sometimes but yeah i mean
therapy is therapy is great i highly
recommend it you know
you cannot
over invest in your mental health and
that that comes from you know someone
who grew up with a psychiatrist for a
dad um
and maybe maybe like you know the
cobblers kids don't have shoes um yeah i
think uh you know now i'm i'm vest
heavily in my mental health there's
there's an unlimited budget for
for that there's a lot of what you were
saying resonates with me very very um
terrifyingly and i the parts that really
i was i was most um intrigued by is i
sometimes think in my romantic
relationship that i
am maybe negligent and i justify it to
myself as because i'm
you know working so hard and i'm trying
to provide so much and i'm you know and
i think
sometimes i'm you know i might think to
myself well they just don't understand
i'm doing all of this hard work and they
should respect you not respect me they
should be more appreciative of all this
hard work i'm doing
and it's such a i know it's such a
selfish way to look at a relationship
because i'm serving myself and then
justifying my my almost neglecting
someone
by saying well i'm basically serving
myself it is actually
and that's yeah you were speaking i was
a bit scared that that's me in some ways
no well
you remember from the film forrest gump
where he's talking to
his girlfriend janie or the girl he
loves and he says you know i'm not a
smart man janae but i do know what love
is and
i feel like i'm the foil for that where
i might i might in some ways be a smart
guy but i'm not at all convinced that i
have any
grasp firm grasp of what love is
um and you know
what is love will this like authentic
real love look like it's probably not
what i
try to give my partner sometimes you
know i mean you know actually
understanding what
what she wants you know i mean sometimes
i'm i'm giving
you know some imaginary
you know construct what i think they
want and then saying well you know you
should have that uh rather than pain
really paying attention and going you
know what is it what is it that makes
you understand and feel loved and known
and appreciated and valued and that's
what i want to do um did you not see
that growing up at all or you just not
taught it
talk you know what i mean because
sometimes you can see it but not know
what's actually going on behind the
scenes so you can see oh they look happy
but not no
yeah no i mean i i think when i look
back on it there were people who i felt
connection with and that i felt you know
some warmth and
um in their presence and you know i
didn't understand that i didn't go
that's love you know that that really is
um you know them seeing me and and and
you know reaching out to me and
connecting with me and um but you know
looking maybe it's only looking back
that you can kind of see those things
accurately and and meaningfully when you
look forward then what are the big what
are the big goals for you and you know
i'm i'm not someone that buys into
making you know vision boards and having
a five-year plan and all that nonsense
because i think there's a certain
agility required to be successful
personally and professionally and
putting your flag too far
you know in the future is probably not a
great idea in that situation but what
are you what are the found when you
think about your life in 10 years time
what will it what will the foundations
of that life look like for it to be a
really great one yeah
well um
i think you know from a business
perspective uh
i i love what i what i get to do i mean
it feels like it doesn't it doesn't you
know feel like work um now um
i mean it feels like a gift to be able
to be a part of this business a part of
this you know a family who who believes
the integrity of their product there's
no
pressure to compromise in any way this
thing that you know that we're doing
and um you know that feels fantastic so
you know i i think that
the team that we've built is is capable
of more i don't know what that is
but i'm excited to see what that could
be
and um and personally you know i think
i've got a lot of growth to do i think
i've just kind of scratched the surface
of the
all the the ways that i cover up the
motivation the true motivations that i
have um
so i wanna i wanna
i wanna go after that with conviction
and competitiveness you know i'm a very
competitive guy i love uh you know
whatever it is that i do i you know i
kind of i kind of go after it um so um
yeah and a lot to read a lot to um
but you know i think
sometimes that
urgency
doesn't work in mental health um and
that kind of you can't rush to
self-awareness
sometimes it kind of sometimes it's you
know kind of like the bird that kind of
lands on your hand when you're when
you're you know being patient um so um i
think i've got to
expand my repertoire of of intensity uh
in that regard one step at a time
and vulnerability being vulnerable i
think is one step at a time and it's
kind of like opening opening the door a
little bit at a time it has been for me
anyway i think because i was so scared
to be vulnerable i think for much of my
life that i tried the experiment of
being vulnerable looked around and it
seemed to be okay it seemed to help me
seem to help others i opened the door a
little bit further it helped me it
helped others
and so over the last couple of years
this is part of the reason we do this
podcast is i've been able to be more
vulnerable and it really is such a
selfish thing because it's the most
unbelievable way to live to just be able
to sit here and talk about masturbation
my sex life mental health i was i've got
anxiety about this it's such a free way
to live the science supports that you
think about those that live most
most
in tune with who they actually are seem
to be the happiest but when i think
about the real adverse consequences you
see sometimes in certain communities who
are not being allowed to live as they
are the suicide rates spike and
everything so
getting closer to your true vulnerable
self i think is such a gift and then the
way it resonates you'll see as a leader
i'm sure you saw in the pandemic
you know vulnerable leaders in the
pandemic i think won vulnerable leaders
when it comes to letting people go
always win
so um no when i was preparing for this
this conversation with you stephen i
went back and looked at some of the
presentations i'd done to my to my
business and one of the presentations
that i did was called
um
have you known hard times
and you know and i went through and
talked about my hard times um and being
able to and to me
that was a real that was a real turning
point as well um saying you know
it's okay it's not only okay it's it's
really important for to to acknowledge
that we've all had really hard times
that like break you apart as a human
being and you know make you make you
question everything um and that's okay
here um that was a um and and then the
feedback that i got to say that that was
that that was you know that was a
positive thing that was that was
amazingly uh um
yeah fulfilling
i am so excited to announce our new
sponsor for this podcast and that is
blue jeans by verizon for any of you
that aren't already familiar with blue
jeans they are a video conferencing and
collaboration tool who offer an
immersive communication experience that
drives pretty unparalleled employee and
customer engagement experiences me and
all of my teams across all of my
portfolio companies switched over to
blue jeans a couple of months ago and we
have not looked back the best thing for
us has been the totally frictionless
experience no glitching no sound issues
no delays or any of those things that
usually make virtual meetings really
really frustrating we use blue jeans
anywhere on any device at any time and
it's perfect for my small businesses
that just have 10 or 20 people to some
of my bigger businesses that have
hundreds of people i'm a big fan as you
can probably tell so i've been quite
excited for for some time to announce
this partnership and in the coming weeks
i'll explain the features and really why
it's perfect for you if you haven't
considered using or switching over to
blue jeans yet but if you can't wait
head over to bluejeans.com to learn more
honestly it's been one of the real sort
of
game changers in my business
um
we do have a closing tradition on this
podcast where the previous guests asked
the next guest you've done your
preparations yes
um
and i don't read it until i open the
book so the question is
oh
who is the person
you'd most like to say sorry to
but haven't
wow
i've got a pretty long list
um
i would say
um
i'd say my my ex-wife
for
um
being
so blind to the things that i brought to
the relationship that must have upset
her for years um
and you know and insisted that you know
that they weren't
um
things that
you know i had said or done and really i
mean i guess i i guess that would apply
to anybody who i've had a romantic
relationship with that you know that i
didn't
um i didn't bring
my true authentic self that even even
though i thought i was um
and i thought i was living a purposeful
you know life um but but didn't
um
but then i'd also i guess i'd say um
[Music]
you know i i think there's a
dynamic with my parents that that
probably
falls into that category of making
amends
and you know as a
um
both as the recipient and the
perpetrator of you know of some
trauma um in that regard um
and then i i guess i'd have to say uh to
hayden and lucy my kids for
um you know for
the for not being there in the moments
when they needed me um and
you know i can blame the uk court system
as much as i want but the fact is that
there were moments where they woke up
and needed both their parents and and in
their and i wasn't there
um
and uh you know i'm
deeply sorry for that um
and
yeah you know and they're and they're
probably um
they're probably lots of others um in
that list um but that's a it's a short
summary
thank you thank you for your time today
thank you for
your wisdom as it relates to business
and the story of five guys which is just
tremendously inspiring and i it's always
such an honor to get to speak to ceos
and operators that have been part of
disruption and really underpinning and
sort of really unpicking
how they've gone about that that's so
immensely valuable to me and i've taken
so much away from from that in terms of
the simplicity in terms of detail in
terms of putting the customer first in
terms of the importance of
talent and this negative hiring concept
which i'm going to adopt in all of my
companies but even more importantly for
me is is the vulnerability that you've
shown and the the human behind all of
that because that's the thing that
ultimately people can resonate with the
most because no matter where we
reach in the in our careers no matter
how how high we climb it seems so
clearly obvious that
when none of us are immune from the the
consequences of just being a human being
and
we can all relate to that regardless of
where we are in the world so thank you
so much it's been such an inspiring
conversation and
hopefully we'll do it again sometime
absolutely pleasure thanks for the time
together
i had a few words to say about one of my
sponsors on this podcast my girlfriend
came upstairs yesterday when i was
having a shower and she said to me that
she tried the heel protein shake which
lives on my fridge over there and she
said it's amazing low calories you get
your 20 odd grams of protein you get
your 26 vitamins and minerals and it's
nutritionally complete in the protein
space there's lots of things but it's
hard to find something that is nice
especially when consumed just with water
and that is nutritionally complete the
salted caramel one if you put some ice
cubes in it and you put it in a blender
and you try it is as good as pretty much
any milkshake on the market just mixed
with water it's been a game changer for
me because i'm trying to drop my calorie
intake and i'm trying to be a little bit
more healthy with my diet so this is
where heel fits in my life thank you for
making a product that i actually like
[Music]